[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren unsere macht wie gewohnt
präsentieren wir heute 55 meinungen ist
wird so aktuell wie nie zuvor wir werden
live in die ukraine blicken und über
kona sprechen meine gäste heute abend
die journalistin katrin seybold 18 jahre
lang für zdf in wie sie selbst sagt
scheinselbstständigkeit tätig war ob die
meinungsfreiheit im öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk gewährt ist darüber
wollen wir heute mit ihr diskutieren
neben e der österreichische ex politiker
kolumnist auto gerät groß er hat mich
schon vor der sendung gewarnt dass seine
meinung zur ukraine eine andere an
meiner seite zumindest digital ein
großartiger kollege der stellvertretende
chefredakteur der bild-zeitung und fiel
nach acht moderator paul ronzheimer es
seit wochen in der ukraine berichtet vor
ort und wir sind gleich sehen wie er
seine sicht erschüttert uns seine sicht
auf die aktuelle lage neben gegen die
deutsche antwort auf die netflix serie
das damen gadget die erfolgreichste
deutsche spielerin elisabeth geht's wir
möchten unsere heutige sendung direkt
mit dem thema vom korn zimmer staaten
uns in die ukraine blicken
pauli möchte zu starten lena ja ich bin
in diesen minuten in der ost ukraine
und hier wird weiter jeden tag
geschossen ich habe heute morgen an der
front wieder erlebt wie mörser granaten
in einem wohngebiet runter gegangen sind
und ich habe erlebt wie verzweifelt
viele menschen und wie viel angst vor
allem auch ukrainischen soldaten davor
haben dass jetzt boutique truppen auf
weitere teile der ukraine einnehmen
können was mich da als deutscher
besonders wütend macht ist dass wir
nicht hart vorgehen
nord stream zwei das haben wir jetzt zum
glück erst einmal ausgesetzt aber auf
der anderen seite gibt es noch viele
viele dinge die wir härter durchführen
konnten zb endlich sanktionen gegen
putins kinder zum beispiel gegen putins
verwandelt gegen alle die putin
unterstützen wir brauchen scharfe
sanktionen gegen regierungsmitarbeiter
gegen minister gegen all diejenigen die
jetzt weiter im westen urlaub machen in
st tropez urlaub machen auch immer
unbedingt machen nein das darf nicht
versagt und gleichzeitig denke ich auch
an altkanzler gerhard schröder ab oder
weise hat gerade seine ehefrau etwas bei
instagram gepostet und hat behauptet so
sinngemäß dass gerd schröder ja zur
vermittlung bereit sein aber die
bundesregierung das nicht wolle die
würde ganz viele angesprochen warum
gerhard schröder denn da nicht etwas tun
könnte mittlerweile hat man diesen
instagram post wieder gelöscht ich finde
gerhard schröder müssen endlich die
dinge gestrichen werden wie wir
steuerzahler weiter bezahlen unter
anderem seinen fahrer seine bodyguard
all diese dinge die verbrecherische
politik von wladimir putin muss bestraft
werden
wer einen konflikt lösen möchte ja uns
heimat werden wahrheit auch in der
ukraine frieden haben möchte und auf dem
europäischen kontinent frieden haben
möchte darf sich nicht wieder kettenhund
des weißen hauses gehen das sage ich
ihnen auch aus der distanz an ihren ort
wo sie sinn wenngleich es auch
dramatisches und die ihre situation
durchaus unter dem eindruck
schrecklicher bilder verstehe aber wenn
wir heute in die ukraine blicken dann
müssen wir doch einige jahrzehnte zurück
gehen und verstehen dass es die
vereinigten staaten von amerika wurden
die hier die grenze von berlin verlassen
haben und sich mit der nato gegen den
osten ausgeweitet haben polen rumänien
slowakei tschechien litauen lettland
rumänien slowenien sehr viele staaten
sind in den einflussbereich der
ehemaligen sowjetunion gerückt und ich
verstehe daher ich kreise keinen kritik
gut ich heiße das blutvergießen nicht
gut aber ich verstehe daher dass putin
eine reaktion zeigen muss denn es kann
ja nicht sein dass atomwaffen
mittelstreckenraketen im vorgarten
moskaus stationiert werden gleichsam
erinnere ich mich an das jahr 1962 wie
der dritte weltkrieg vor der tür stand
weil nikita chruschtschow auf kuba
washington und die vereinigten staaten
bedroht hat damals war das wetter und
adresse diesmal ist es ein bruch
schwacher us präsidenten und diese zeit
wahrscheinlich um ideen verbinden liegt
und oester und europa österreich
deutschland die eu-staaten frankreich
sind die nützlichen idioten einer nato
politik anstatt dass wir hier in dieser
situation eine eigenständige aus und
sicherheitspolitik vertreten die
bedeutet hätte dass wir frieden schaffen
indem wir die ukraine der ukraine
empfehlen sich neutral zu erklären wie
es beispielsweise in österreich oder die
schweiz ist und wie er es europäische
union ganz klare beitrittsperspektive
die nächsten 15 20 jahre auf lassen sie
uns darauf doch direkt per holzheim
beantworten würde ich sagen es war ja
fast schon eine staatsmännische reden
hier von ergic foul weil deine antwort
darauf ja eine sehr verwirrende rede
denn man muss sagen dass natürlich jedes
land und eine bündnisfreiheit garantiert
worden ist dass auch russland damit
einverstanden war das ein und andere
diese freie wahl haben und es keine
gegenwehr gab nein es gibt eine
bündnisfreiheit und jedes eigenständige
land darf natürlich selbst entscheiden
ob es mitglied der nato werden will oder
nicht was die ukraine angeht da muss man
gar nicht so weit zurück gucken man muss
eigentlich nur auf 1994 schauen da
wurden der ukraine nämlich
sicherheitsgarantien ausgestellt und
zwar im gegenzug dafür dass sie ihre
atomwaffen abgegeben haben hat russland
und die westliche welt in diese
sicherheits garantien ausgesprochen und
jetzt müssen wir uns anschauen was
gerade passiert
herr gross da gab es zum einen die
aktion der krim 2014 es gab dann die
putins schergen hier wenige kilometer
von mir entfernt wo ich gerade stehe die
bereits einen krieg geführt haben und
jetzt gibt es panzer die mittlerweile
von der russischen grenze in richtung
separatisten gebiet das schon vorher von
den airbus unterstützt worden ist war
das lade ich mir putin fährt eine
aggressive aggressivste politik und er
hat in seiner rede gestern behauptet
dass die ukraine kein eigenständiger
stark sein dass diese ukraine zu
russland gehöre habt ihr die
eigenständigkeit abgesprochen das ist
das was das wirklich grausame ist was
hier passiert und da können sie nicht
kommen und sagen deutlich ukraine doch
mal jetzt bitte anfang neutral zu sein
die ukraine hat 1994 noch einmal atom
was abgegeben hat als sicherheits
garantien bekommen und wir sehen ja was
hier gerade passiert ist und was dieses
nato gelaber muss ich sagen angeht es
ist doch so dass deutschland und
frankreich 2008 bereits gesagt haben die
ukraine man lebens die nato
mitgliedschaft ab besteht momentan
überhaupt nicht auf der tagesordnung
und zweifelsohne etwas putin aggressiv
agiert aber noch einmal man muss des
busses kern trifft man muss die ursache
treffen man muss wissen warum er so
agiert wenn man mit putin verhandeln
will muss man putin verstehen nun darf
man nicht vergessen dass die ukraine aus
sowjetischer staat wollen dann darf man
nicht vergessen dass heute noch genug
russen in der ukraine leben nun darf man
nicht vergessen dass österreich zum
beispiel auch verpflichtungen gegenüber
südtirol hat der schutzmacht dass solche
mechanismen immer gegolten haben und das
im übrigen auch zu hören auf dem zweiten
weltkrieg noch immer wie eine gewisse
verpflichtung gegenüber den südtirolern
haben und da muss man auch verstehen
dass der kreml oder russland putin und
noch einmal ich bin weder die kraft noch
der knecht des kreml sowie bin nicht so
deppert und bin dass klar wird der nato
sondern wie viele europäer und bin 77
geboren europäisch sozialisiert in einer
sozialen marktwirtschaft und bin nicht
der handlanger der billige eines
vollkommen vertrottelten us-präsidenten
und auch nicht jedes jahr putin man muss
verstehen dass putin hier angst hat dass
die nato sich ausweitet und diesmal
direkt vor seine grenze die ukraine ist
der puffer zwischen den nato-staaten und
seiner grenze und daher darf man nicht
vergessen dass er hier auch eine
grenzziehung machen muss so mir geht
jetzt aber nicht darum dass ich ihren
aufenthalten runzheimer in der ukraine
verlängere damit sie blut sehen und über
sonstiges berichten mir geht es darum
wie führen wir diese gerne mit wie viel
das war ein fahrer kommen und wie kommen
wir uns das sagt asse aus und wie kommen
wir aus der sackgasse heraus indem die
ukraine erklärt und auch ihre
verfassungsbestimmungen gilt in dem sie
ihm nicht der nato beitritt erster punkt
und dafür übernehmen wir europa
sicherheitsgarantien für die ukraine und
dafür müsste auch russland eine
souveränitäts erklärung für die ukraine
abgeben und schluss ist der zirkus und
dann kann sich daher beiden mit der nato
verziehen weil dann hat die nato hier
auch nichts mehr verloren
weil ich lasse sich der hunger groß
raten also das was sie dort ernsthaft
jetzt den krieg hier mit
österreichischen beziehungen zu tirol
vergleicht und bilden vergleich gekommen
was irgendwie österreich vertrag nicht
nur mit tirol hat so tief bin ich nicht
der österreichischen politik auch wenn
ich dafür interessiere allerdings muss
ich sagen es ist doch so selbst wenn die
ukraine sagen würde sie verzichtet auf
die nato-mitgliedschaft selbst dann
würde putin doch nicht aufhören er hat
gerade drei bedingungen gestellt der
abgesagt usain soll die annexion der
krim akzeptieren er hat gesagt sie soll
am ende der ganzen sache keine nato
mitgliedschaft eben und er hat die
entmilitarisierung der ukraine gefordert
und man darf das doch nicht vergessen
was er vorher in dieser rede gesagt hat
nämlich dass er sagt die ukraine gehört
zu russland er hat der ukraine in
wahrheit das existenzrecht abgesprochen
dann können sie doch nicht kommen und
sagen es ging hier nur um die nach und
was am ende kann uns auch das egal sein
denn es geht doch darum wie europa
tatsächlich gemeinsam mit westlichen
partner das sind unsere partner darauf
reagiert oder scholz und andere haben
doch alles versucht und mit putin
diplomatisch ansprechen viel zu viel aus
meiner sicht aber und das ist doch etwas
wo man sagen muss dass wladimir putin
hier der aggressor ist und er stellt
immer neue forderungen an die ukraine
und er will am ende ich das ganze land
ja einverleibt und da geht es nicht
darum diese absurditäten die nato sei an
den rand gerückt der situation hat sich
in den vergangenen 10 15 20 jahren was
die ukraine angeht nichts verändert die
ukraine wird nicht teil der nato in den
in den nächsten jahren aber das ist doch
nur ein vorgeschobener grund und reden
sie doch auch einmal über bloody mit
putins lügen was er hier verbreitet dass
luca ihnen angreifen würde das sind pure
lügen was er sagt dass russen
unterdrückt werden das sind pure lügen
sie können doch nicht ernsthaft so
argumentieren
herunter schauen sie ich gebe ihnen
vollkommen recht putin versucht zu
verhandeln putin versucht zu pokern
putin doppelt natürlich auch weil er
weiß dass es am 1 eine
verhandlungslösung geben wird und daher
kann man auch die forderungen wie zum
kleinen rede ist hier an der richtigen
behandlung aber er und er über akten der
losheimer herum sein mag ein alter hast
du gesehen hast herum thermometer von
ihr entfernen die in die ost ukraine
fahren das ist keine verhandlungslösung
das ist eine invasion und das ist ein
krieg ja aber wir gehen davon aus dass
die invasion nicht in kiew stattfinden
wird er so passiert ja gerade heute noch
der unterschied ja ja ist die umkehrung
seiner größe die können doch nicht sagen
das ist eine verhandlungslösung gibt
band fakten heraus wären dann müsste er
schon bei der realität klar heraus
heimat da geht es um gebietet die quasi
auch mit sehr viele russen die dort ihr
leben die jetzt in
wir uns einmal hören sie mir deswegen
ist es nicht mehr die ukraine werden uns
aber ich halte selbst das für falsch ich
halte selbst diesen einmarsch für euch
noch einmal verwechslung sie mir nicht
mit dem knecht münchen glücklich heidel
sie glauben dass bisher diplomatie
stattgefunden hat so die bisher
überhaupt keine diplomatie stattgefunden
jetzt ist wenn man nur gegenüber
gesessen und im bund wieder gesehen wenn
dafür ein anhaltender minister
miteinander oder älter sowie dass das
sind menschen die nicht einmal in ihren
eigenen ländern ernst genommen werden
also warum solche unternehmen
paul hat ja eine etwas schwieriger
position bei zu gescheitert ist wir
lassen es gehe wohl darum antworten
sonst glaube ich wird sie auch schon
ganze sache gehen paul damit du auch in
ruhe antworten kannst weil du bist ja
etwas eher schwierigeren lage gerade
ich hoffe man hat gehört dass ich gesagt
habe von daher kann ich jetzt nicht noch
einmal alles wiederholen aber es ist so
das ist natürlich versucht wurde mit
wladimir putin zu verhandeln im mehrfach
und olaf scholz ist der deutsche
bundeskanzler mehrheit gewählt worden
von daher glaube ich schon dass er von
einer gewissen anzahl zumindest der
deutschen respektiert wird genauso wie
immer noch immer kann man muss es
einfach so klar sagen bleibt die mir gut
ist in seiner eigenen völlig wahnsinnige
welt noch einmal hat der ukraine das
existenzrecht abgesprochen er hat nicht
gesagt bitte geht nicht in die nato dann
ist alles gut nein er hat gesagt jene
ist integraler bestandteil russland und
er hat das ausgeweitet wladimir putin
will die sowjetunion so wie sie einst
zurück haben und das ist das wahre ziel
von ihm und deswegen ist es wirklich
dramatisch wenn man hier wie ich in
dieser situation ist und er lebt was
hier passiert dass fakten geschaffen
werden dass panzer hier sind dass
wladimir putin das budweiser angekündigt
hat dass es immer noch menschen oder
ehemalige politiker gibt die ernst hat
die schuld bei west ham
aber wir das deutsche selbstverständnis
nicht beleidigen aber sie haben mir
vorher nicht aus
losheim ich bleibe dabei leider es tut
mir selbst leid auch für die großartige
bundesrepublik deutschland aber ihre
freiberg und der schuld mit 26 prozent
kanzler zustimmung werden heute nicht
international ernst genommen sie sind in
wahrheit leider einstellen andere länder
leben lang bleiben dieses faktum wer
jetzt noch mal ein ganz anderes thema
wir besprechen jetzt mal nicht wie herr
scholz und frau bernburg in der welt
wahrgenommen werden dass das nämlich
heute nicht unser thema stattdessen
möchte auch ich heute abend über die
ukraine sprechen ich habe natürlich
weitaus nicht den einblick wie mein
kollege paul wohnzimmer der deswegen
auch an meiner seite ist aber ich möchte
ein thema vorstellen was mich bewegt und
zwar ist es die energiepreis explosion
die uns drohen könnte deswegen mein
thema die energiepreis explosion sie
muss nämlich verhindert werden
deutschland legte putin pipeline nord
stream 2 auf eis und russland baut
sofort ein schreck szenario auf
russlands ex präsident dmitri medwedew
wird in europa die angst vor
explodierenden energiepreisen naja es
gibt ja so viel sagen am dienstag bei
twitter zitat herzlich willkommen in
einer neuen welt wo die europäer bald
schon 2000 euro pro 1000 kubikmeter gas
zahlen werden das bedeutet im klartext
der präsident der ex präsident spricht
von einer möglichen verdopplung der
gaspreise für die kunden in europa stand
jetzt ist es so dass 10.000 kubikmeter
gas kostet in der eu rund 900 euro die
deutsche politik muss jetzt endlich
aufwachen wir dürfen uns nicht noch
stärker in die abhängigkeit von russland
begeben die harte wahrheit ist aktuell
sind wir abhängig aber wir müssen jetzt
mit vollgas in alternative energieträger
investiert kurzfristig atomkraft
langfristig wasserstoff aber jetzt bin
ich froh dazu die meinung von meinem
kollegen vor ort zu haben
janina ich geb dir vollkommen recht wir
hätten schon längst viel unabhängiger
werden müssten vom russischen gas und
das ist ein scheitern der deutschen
politik in den vergangenen 20 jahren
angefangen mit gerhard schröder und dem
architekten der gesamten russischen
außenpolitik das war frank walter
steinmeier der heutige bundespräsident
dann ging es weiter mit angela merkel
mit olaf scholz alle wollten daran
festhalten dass wir eben keine
alternativen finden und man hat bis
zuletzt passt zur verzweifelung als an
nordstream zwei sich geklammert obwohl
klar war dass wenn wir uns abhängig
machen von russischem gas wie erpressbar
sind
wie sehen sie das wenn wir hier mal in
die runde fragen bei das doppel zwischen
den beiden herren ein wenig auflösen was
würden sie sagen wie wir in der zukunft
frau sei damit umgehen mit den
steigenden energiepreisen auch mit blick
auf die russlandkrise also ich halte
atomkraft für keine wirklich veritable
lösungen sie haben den guten zwischen
vorschlag gemacht wir brauchen eine
übergangslösung das ist nicht einfach
also wenn ich mit ece fahrer dann sehe
ich ja so wie es auch immer wieder und
immer öfter große paneelen felder große
flächen die jetzt neu genutzt werden ich
glaube aber tatsächlich ist ist eine
wichtige sache dass wir in alternative
energien investieren ich mache mir
sorgen um die wälder hier in europa weil
das einfach immer mehr wälder gibt wo
dann plötzlich ganz viel windparks
hineingesetzt werden zum beispiel der
wunderschöne reinhardswald in hessen ich
wohne in hessen das ist ein märchenwald
da gibt es viele alte buchen viele
eichen und ich als naturliebhaberin
mache mir da wirklich sorgen um diese
alten wälder auch wenn ich natürlich
grundsätzlich für alternative
energieträger und energiequellen bin
weiß ich nicht wie wird er weitermachen
also ich bin muss ehrlich sagen ein
bisschen ratlos es gibt nicht so
wirklich die königs lösung
naja es ist eine schwierige situation
ich möchte zur bahre unscheinbar jetzt
keine persönlichen worte richten aber
erweitern
sondern natürlich haben wir uns von
russland energietechnische abhängig
gemacht da hat er recht so wie wir uns
von den saudis abhängig gemacht haben
und so wie wir uns von den amerikanern
abhängig gemacht haben wenn man also
einen energieautarken kontinent haben
will dann wird man sich auf diesem
kontinent depressiven den letzten jahren
aus amerika importiert würden weiß noch
teurer
es ist ja auch lars seite mit wer es
gesagt hat das kostet das doppelte in
wahrheit wenn die europäer dazu bereit
sind den preis zu zahlen es ist darüber
zu diskutieren auch im hinblick auf die
ganze klimawandel debatte um den umstieg
auf e mobilität was das am ende
bedeutete und am ende bedeutet dass in
wahrheit und auch das zielt alles ab die
ukraine debatte ist ziemlich die
klimawandel debatte es zielt auf die
renaissance der atomkraft ab und das
sollten wir uns nicht in den sack lügen
ich bin dagegen der atomkraft denn wir
österreicher haben ein eigenes problem
mit der atomkraft wir haben ein
atomkraftwerk das nie in betrieb
genommen wurde weil es durch eine
volksabstimmung
sprichwörtlich versenkt wurde aber was
bedeuten die begehrlichkeiten der grünen
in der deutschen bundesregierung das
erst jeder ford nun in zukunft mit dem
auto feinstaub gibt es deswegen trenne
er recht denken die grünen ändern
ständig weil sie können sich auch nur
dieses eine konzentriert die grünen das
ist ihr einziges verdienst dass ihnen
der rest rennen bis heute egal
was bedeutet dass die der umstieg der
gesamten flotte auf e-mobilität es
bedeutet am ende die abhängigkeit
russland für uns heimat recht die
abhängigkeit füge ich hinzu saudis und
amerika es bedeutete am ende die
renaissance der atomkraft
ob das im sinne des erfinders man wagner
sowie zweifel und gesagt mit also nur
kurzfristig ich bin davon überzeugt dass
wir jetzt extrem für die forschung
investieren müssen um den energieträger
wasserstoff
zukunftssicher zu machen dass der auch
uns in der zukunft helfen wird
um energie viel zu schneider x naja
achtung ich bin 1986 durfte ich drei
monate nicht in einem sandkasten
weil tschernobyl in die luft gegangen
ist und wir durften monate lang ein
schwamm und essen bild wie verleger
nennt sich das in deutschland damit mich
alle verstehen also ich habe aber auch
so kojima erlebt also ich hab schon
einen etwas anderen zugang wir werden in
österreich bedroht durch den berlin
durch christo die steht auf
erdbebenlinie sun schrottreaktoren wenn
es eine sichere technologie gibt und
dort treffen wir uns beide wieder das
bedeutet wenn die technologie und die
wissenschaft voranschreitet und uns eine
sichere und saubere energieform bietet
bin ich der erste der sagt ich finde
aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass
eine frage der aufmerksamkeit lenkung
ist also bei den salzburger festspielen
bei der eröffnung 2020 da gab es neben
der eröffnungsveranstaltung eine riesige
demonstration von den sogenannten
indigenen dass österreichs also
salzburger umland die demonstriert wie
gegeben keine energie trasse und kein
medium ist drauf gegangen ja also die
kameras waren gerichtet auch die tollen
gäste in ihren roben und das ist die
salzburger festspielen frau rabl stadler
und so weiter das war alles wunderbar
aber geht die eigentlich so wichtig auch
die aufmerksamkeit verdient hat werden
und wo es auch möglich gebrannt hat da
hat keine kamera das auge aufgerichtet
und da ist die frage wie wir mit der
energiepolitik vorankommen wenn wir
nicht auch gucken dass wir medial das
auge in die richtige richtung lenken
also dann wäre jetzt sogar mal einigung
am tisch die abhängigkeit muss weniger
werden ich würde gerne noch ein wenig
meiner seine zeit nutzung der paul noch
eine frage zu stellen die mich sehr
interessiert und zwar abschließend zum
ukraine komplex auch heute abend wie
schätzt du ein was joe biden heute
gesagt hat er hat ja eine rede gehalten
und hat dort ja auch auf 92 hingewiesen
was erwarten wir von dem amerikanischen
präsident oder was können wir auch als
deutschland den nächsten wochen erwarten
monaten
ich glaube es war eine klare antwort des
us präsidenten aber nichts was war die
mit putin beeindrucken würde denn er
weiß genau was der westen gut er hat
jeden schritt genau voraus geplant so
scheint es zumindest und ich glaube
nicht dass er sich von dem in
irgendeiner form beeindrucken lässt ich
glaube er wird weiter das tun was er
bereits in den vergangenen 24 stunden in
den vergangenen tagen gemacht hat er
wird fakten schaffen und das dramatische
für die menschen
die ukraine ist für diejenigen die einen
ukrainischen staat behalten wollen und
das ist die ganz ganz große mehrheit für
die bedeutet ist dass sie auf sich
allein gestellt denn joe biden hat
gesagt es wird ein amerikaner kein
nato-soldat ihr eingesetzt werden die
ukraine ist nicht teil der nato insofern
muss man ganz klar sagen die menschen
die 2014 da mal daran für ihre freiheit
kämpfen
wir sind auch jetzt bei einer sehr
wahrscheinlichen weiteren aggressions
russlands auf sich alleine gestellt
wir werden du bleibst es ja heute
erhalten in der sendung ich freue mich
sehr ich hab's ja vermisst mit de zu
sitzen jetzt habe ich nicht wenigstens
die dem tal an seiner seite du hast ja
um eine sehr dezidierte meinung zu
corona wir gehen nämlich jetzt weiter
zum nächsten thema möchten ihnen aber
auch versprechen liebe zuschauer bleiben
nicht nur bei bild live dran sondern
auch jeden abend bei film nachts wenn
wir immer wieder in die ukraine schauen
und jetzt geht es weiter ich möchte mich
hier schon mal vorab für den mut
bedanken den frau seit heute am
mitgebracht hat weil sie spricht jetzt
über den alten arbeitgeber nicht
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk
ja ich sehe die meinungsfreiheit in der
berichterstattung von zdf 3sat nicht
mehr gewährleistet dann zum beispiel in
meinem beitrag über hashtag alles
dichtmachen wurde meine freie meinung in
meinem beitrag platt gemacht durch die
auswahl eines gesprächs gastes in
ähnlicher form ging es meiner kollegen
die ein halbes jahr später einen beitrag
macht über hashtag alles auf den tisch
sie musste um schneiden sie wurde
gezwungen zu einem gesprächspartner zu
fahren und nach zu drehen die sind zu
interviewen der dann die aktion als
kriminell bezeichnet hat und mein zdf
arbeitgeber ein ehemaliger arbeitgeber
hat es mir sogar schriftlich gegeben
dass das was die vierte gewalt ausmacht
nicht mehr gefragt dass ich habe in
meiner kündigung in meinem
kündigungsschreiben schriftlich bekommen
zitat
redaktionssitzungen werden von innen
immer wieder für kritik am system
genutzt was bei kolleginnen erhebliche
stöhr gefühle auslöst und zitat das
vertrauensverhältnis ist durch ihr
verhalten so nachhaltig beschädigt dass
die beschäftigung nach ablauf des
honorar zeit vertrages für uns nicht
mehr vorstellbar ist wie lange waren sie
jetzt für den öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk tätig frau seibold ich habe 18
jahre lang gearbeitet also um genau zu
sein ich glaube 1999 wurde ich für die
heute seine nummer gecastet da war ich
aber erst in meinen frühen zwanzigern
hat beschloss ich muss erstmal ein
studium zu ende machen und so richtig
los ging es dann eigentlich mit dem zdf
new york nach der journalistenschule da
habe ich eine station als hospitanten
gemacht und habe zum ersten mal fake
news produktion miterlebt
in ihr kann man das so hart sagen die
jahresproduktion das ist ja wirklich ein
sehr harter vorwurf er inwiefern also
der damalige korrespondent udo van
kampen bekam aus mainz die nachricht wir
haben hier eine meldung das war auch
kurz auf der rampe zum irak giftgas
alarm in new york alarmstufe orange und
wir haben dann recherchiert ob das
wirklich der fall ist in new york wir
haben keine belege gefunden aber mainz
die zentrale zdf brauchte einen beitrag
für die aktualität
sodann hat der konsument gesagt vista
was leute wir brauchen den beitrag dann
sind wir in die korrespondenten wohnung
gefahren und der kameramann hat dann
also den heraus geklingelt nachbarn
gefilmt wie der also auf geheiß des
kochs modell mit die fenster ritzen mit
einem back tape abgedichtet hatten es
könnte er giftgas eintreten sodann
nachdem das abgedreht waren wurde ich
geschickt mit einem kamerateam zu einem
laden wo gasmasken zu sehen waren mit
dem auftrag möglichst auch leute zu
finden die sagen ich habe panik vor
einem giftgas alarm natürlich habe ich
keine leute gefunden
da war er gähnt leerer laden mit einem
schaufenster gruppe mit giftgas masken
die haben wir dann brav gedreht und dann
habe ich einen anruf bekommen von der
producerin wir haben es also doch einen
laden gefunden wo man auch menschen mit
o-tönen bekommen hat die sagen ja wir
haben giftgas angst also angst vor einem
giftgasangriff in new york und diese
beiträge diese beschuldigung dieses
filmer teilhaben zusammengeschnitten zu
einem beitrag und der wurde dann mitte
februar 2003 vom zdf in einer aktuellen
sendung ausgestrahlt findet man immer
noch im archiv und sie sind ja dann
geblieben trotz dieser produktion die
sich schon wirklich sehr skurril einheit
aber wann hatten sie denn jetzt in der
krone zeit das gefühl dass ihre kritik
nicht mehr angenommen wird sie wirklich
auch gar keine andere meinung haben
sollten wir das schreiben die kündigung
ganz klar zeigt
also das ist ein schleichender prozess
gewesen sage ich mal es gab verschiedene
zwischenstufen aber es ist schon so dass
es immer schwieriger war bestimmte
themen anzusprechen fragen zu stellen
also ich sag mal das thema kinder in
kurzer zeit war eigentlich viel zu stark
unterbelichtet also da da gab es
irgendwie so eine art sperre ich habe
gesagt wir müssen doch jetzt mal endlich
gruppen wie geht es denen eigentlich wer
als kultursendung als vierter im
fernsehen haben immer über sprache
reflektiert und ich habe zum beispiel
die frage gestellt was ist denn mit dem
begriff querdenker passiert also vor
corinna wollte jeder gute chef
mindestens zwei querdenker im team haben
und jetzt ist es so ein tabu das man auf
keinen fall damit auch nur in verbindung
gebracht werden möchte wer hat es
erfunden war das eine finca oder warum
übernehmen wir das so unreflektiert
diese diskussion war eigentlich nicht zu
führen also ich habe auch ganz oft
schweigen müssen weil ich wusste es
funktioniert nicht und wenn ich versucht
habe rein zu gehen die diskussionen und
das habe ich leider sehr oft gemacht
dann waren es immer so dass ich schon
wusste als denkt die hälfte der
redaktion als kommt sie schon wieder und
irgendwann was sagt dann auch einfach
die sprache und es ist ihnen auch
wirklich nicht mehr möglich gewesen
neutrale beiträge oder mit ihrer meinung
nach machen also meine meinung sagen
durfte ich immer da glaube ich gibt es
auch ganz viele aussagen von kollegen
aus anderen aktuellen redaktionen die
sagen na ja wir können schon sagen was
wir denken aber am ende heißt dann immer
danke für das kontroverse meinungsbild
was machen heute abend chor ohne zahlen
oder bei uns setzen wir haben wir nicht
zahlen als kultursendung sondern wir
machen dann halt wieder das was sowieso
gefragt ist frau ps kann man denn den
medien noch glauben wenn sie das jetzt
sie gerade zu hören was empfinden sie
dann wenn sie das als bürgerin hören sie
müssen ja auch verstehen ich bin ein
kind aus der ddr und natürlich die
menschen die aus der ddr kommen die
waren immer gegenüber der regierung und
den medien natürlich viel vorsichtiger
eingestellt als westliche länder dadurch
habe ich natürlich auch eine ganze
portion misstrauen von meinen eltern
mitbekommen logischerweise weil sie
damals eben unter der zeit der stasi
sehr gelitten haben und als
schachspieler vor allem ist es immer
unsere aufgabe mindestens in einer
schachpartie sämtliche sachen zu
hinterfragen und dann natürlich gibt es
bei der korona medien erstattung so
viele offene fragen die gar nicht
thematisiert oder diskutiert werden wo
man sich am ende denkt wo ist die logik
warum ist das so warum wird das nicht
erklärt warum gibt es dafür keine
offiziellen belege oder beweise zum
beispiel sagt lauterbach na ja wir haben
ohne diese maßnahmen mindestens 400 bis
500 todesopfer jeden tag zu verzeichnen
und er redet durch den maßnahmen leben
gibt es dafür irgendwelche statistischen
bilder oder analysen sieht man ich es
sind einfach zahlen die irgendwo in den
raum geschmissen werden ohne dass wir
uns darunter irgendwie etwas vorstellen
können ohne dass es da irgendwas
ersichtlich es gibt um das ganze
nachzuvollziehen und mittlerweile ist
das meines erachtens vor allem auch in
der meinungsfreiheit so krass geworden
dass man sich selber schon die frage
stellen muss was darf ich überhaupt mir
noch erlaubten zu sagen ohne
gebrandmarkt zu werden ohne mein gesicht
zu verlieren und das geht wahrscheinlich
nicht nur den zdf redakteuren sondern es
ist in jedem bereich der fall selbst im
sportbereich muss man mittlerweile
verdammt aufpassen wie man sich
gegenüber dem pandemie maßnahmen et
cetera äußert und es heutzutage ist der
spruch ganz klug reden ist silber
schweigen ist gold paul du hast ja kein
lauter aber oft interviewt auch hart
angegangen wie ich finde was hast du
denn gerade empfinde ich mein wenn frau
sei aber das so erzählt wie fandest du
denn die medienberichterstattung in
corona zeitalter ja vielleicht auch mit
blick auf der lauterbach
ja da kann ich jetzt in den details
natürlich wenig zu sagen wie sich das
ganze dort zugetragen hat ich glaube es
gibt bei den öffentlich-rechtlichen
genauso wie in allen anderen medien
solche und solche
aus meiner sicht tolle reporter und
weniger gute und ich glaube das ist
etwas was jetzt nicht speziell auf den
öffentlich rechtlichen
bereich zu münzen ist sozusagen was karl
lauterbach angeht sicherlich da gab es
am anfang eine berichterstattung glaube
ich die sehr wohlwollend war ich selbst
habe ihn ja wenn du noch acht auch als
möglichen
außenministern 1 als glücklich
gesundheitsminister genannt und habe
mich dafür ausgesprochen insbesondere
weil ich es absurd gefunden hätte wenn
die spd wenn sie denn dieses ministerium
bekommt sich nicht für karl lauterbach
aussprechen würde aber da muss man sagen
nicht nur bilder sondern auch andere
medien die welt aber auch die
süddeutsche der spiegel gehen durchaus
mittlerweile kritisch mit herr
lauterbach oben deswegen finde ich dass
die vorurteile dass man sagt dass jetzt
diese ausschließlich positiv begleitet
würden die stimmen nicht aus meiner
sicht eine sache vielleicht noch zum
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk ich fand
es interessant um dann doch noch mal
kurz auf die ukraine bekommen wie heute
einigen kolleginnen bei twitter
geschrieben hat das
sieht man eine kollegin in berlin glaube
ich arbeitete im hauptstadtbüro die
gesagt hat die menschen würden sich ja
einmal beklagen über den
öffentlich-rechtlichen rundfunkgebühren
und dass die gebühren nicht erhöhen
könnte und dann sollte man sich auch
nicht wundern so sind gemäss dass es
keine sondersendung zur gestrigen lage
gegeben hat als gerade putin angekündigt
hat hier diese sogenannten volksrepublik
anzuerkennen da ist dann eine große
debatte entstanden bei twitter hat
jemand gespielt dafür 27
hätte man das wir bekommen und wie
konnte das sein also das ist schon sehr
absurd bei 1 9 milliarden gebührengelder
das war ein reporter sagen man sei damit
nicht imstande eine vernünftige
berichterstattung eine sondersendung zu
machen und das fällt mir ehrlich gesagt
als auslandsreporter immer wieder
aufgeht sondern weil ich jetzt von
privaten medien aber dass zum beispiel
bbc die
berichterstattung sehr sehr viel besser
aufwendiger und kompetenter und
kompetenter macht insbesondere aus dem
ausland also da muss ich mal ganz kurz
rein gehen also wir hatten einen sturm
aufs kapital und da ist ein zdf einfach
sind einfach furchtbare pleiten passiert
das liegt aber nicht daran wie viel geld
zur verfügung ist sondern das geld wird
einfach sehr zweifelhaft eingesetzt nur
kleine fussnote das zdf hat einen
eigenen angestellten der kunst kauft
also der hat einen bus nach mainz geholt
also so viel geld hat der
öffentlich-rechtliche rundfunk was viele
mitarbeiter gar nicht wissen dass werden
momentan auch neubauten geplant auf dem
zdf gelände für 45 einfach mal so für
einen nachhaltigen neubau plus 14,5
prozent teuerungsrate daneben wird das
studio n renoviert also davon wo die
heute und es heute schon mal gefahren
werden hat nach 13 jahren nach neuer
baum ein kaputtes undichtes dach also
man muss ein bisschen alito mentschow
denk mir wo es dann schon rein tropft
nach 13 jahren und man dann das ganze
dach runter nehmen muss damit es dann
noch dicht ist und nicht irgendwie oben
mal so der tropfen raus jedenfalls ich
finde das einen wichtigen punkt den die
kollegen da gemacht hat der heute diese
diskussion ausgelöst hat denn für den
einzelnen mitarbeiter scheint ist oft so
dass einfach nicht genügend geld da ist
also da ist not da auf der individuellen
redaktionellen ebene immer weniger geld
für journalismus immer mehr geld für zum
beispiel neubauten in österreich hat der
franz ja auch eine benchmark gesetzt
also sich ein denkmal in dem er dieses
multifunktionsgebäude dahin gesetzt hat
das war sein markenzeichen seine runde
markus raschke dafür ist er bekannt
geworden beim orf und jetzt kommt der
neue muss man schauen was der macht aber
ich finde trotzdem
man muss jetzt mal ganz kritisch
hinschauen wie wir uns einbringen können
wie können wir als gebührenzahlung wir
sind ja alle so lange wir in deutschland
wohnen gebührenzahler auch in österreich
wir können weder überhaupt etwas ändern
und ich glaube da ist einfach guter rat
teuer wir brauchen konzepte an denen man
das festmachen kann dass wir auch wieder
eingreifen können weil das ist fakt ich
in der redaktion die haben so viele
zuschauer zuschriften bekommen und das
ist dann immer so naja und kann ja eh
keiner was also man schreibt eine
diplomatische antwort dies dann auch
ganz genehm für uns ja und der andere
bekommt auch was aber dass man wirklich
darauf eingeht uns guckt was möchten
denn die menschen worauf haben sie auch
ein recht an berichterstattung das wird
viel zu wenig beachtet und natürlich
auch wo gehen die großen beträge hin
also definitiv sind neubauten aus meiner
sicht das falsche und in der tat wie die
kollegen schon richtig gesagt hat heute
es braucht mehr geld für guten
journalismus und für programm was vor
ort stattfindet wo wirklich die
journalistischen qualität noch wieder
zum tragen kommen das sich momentan
ziemlich gefährdet herr gross wie sie
mit blick auf österreich wenn sie jetzt
hier hören fehlende meinungspluralität
beim öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk das
geld für neubauten raus dieses denn bei
ihnen österreich teilweise landschaft
meine überraschung hält sich darüber in
grenzen dass wir es mit einem
öffentlich-rechtlichen mittlerweile mit
brainwash anstalten zu tun haben die
keinen information journalismus mehr
vertreten sondern nur meine meinung
journalismus also das was wir aus dem
print journalismus aus da aus dem
kommentar des chefredakteurs kennen das
übertragen wird in die
öffentlich-rechtliche information ist
nichts neues und als keulen gelten dann
die kanzel culture mit denen unliebsame
auftretende gekillt werden in wahrheit
im übrigen gratuliere ihnen zu ihrem mut
ich hoffe für sie dass sie natürlich
schon ein tag auf ihre faire einem
scheiterhaufen des
öffentlich-rechtlichen landen wenn sie
hier auch so großzügig mit ihrer
informations hing wie es denn
tatsächlich ausschaut also von herzen
hut ab vor ihnen und respekt wie sie das
hier anlegen das problem ist der
öffentlich-rechtliche hat auch keine
qualitätskontrolle mehr der
öffentlich-rechtliche kriegt egal ob er
schon produziert ob fake news produziert
aber meinungsjournalismus vertritt oder
vielleicht auch nur objektive
information immer die gleichen gebühren
egal ob die hälfte der gebührenzahler
belässt er längst für dieses roth tv
wegschalten habe niemanden mehr als wir
erleben ja nichts anderes ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass steigerungs zahlen
bei den quoten für zdf ard oder bei orf
geht die jammern jedes jahr über
sinkende zuseher kassieren aber sehr
wohl die volle gage für ein programm in
wahrheit mit dem wir ja nicht einmal
mehr den toten 100 hinter dem ofen
hervor locken und doch bin ich jetzt
wieder bei den herren runzheimer das ist
schon ein stück ich erkenne die dramatik
in der ukraine sich abspielt und wenn
der öffentlich-rechtliche zuerst eine
siebenstündige sitzung organisieren muss
ob sie denn vielleicht nicht einen sende
wagen klicken und dann kann uns darauf
dass das ende waren aber nicht bedankt
ist und dann kommt als verantwortliche
darauf dass das ende wagen nicht
geschickt werden kann weil das kostet
14.000 euro wo man kauft dann ab um zwei
millionen euro an oder man saniert die
büros der generaldirektoren ja dann wird
halt ein wenig problematisch mit dem
vertrauen der menschen sprich der
gebühren aber das ist viel einfacher
ehrlich gesagt also es geht einfach
darum was macht man aus dem was man hat
also zum stichwort bbc herr ronzheimer
beim sturm aufs kapital da kam ich eben
vorher kurz darauf einfach der
bbc-reporter zusammen mit einem pbs ab
heute und einem tv-reporter als einziger
den schritt gewagt in dieses kapitel
reinzugehen live und das kann man wenn
man ein handy in der tasche hat und dem
knopf im ohr dann kann ich in youtube
oder in was auch immer live gehen und
auch an den zuschauer mitnehmen in
dieses gefüge und der zdf korrespondent
hat das gegenteil davon gemacht der hat
zwar natürlich wie immer hat das zdf
auch das recht auf seiner seite versucht
seitdem mannschaft zu schützen
die kameraleute und so weiter aber
danach gab es interne große diskussion
wie das eigentlich sein kann dass da
jemand einfach einen pakt und das dann
wird zur gleichen zeit der claus kleber
twittert bitte jetzt alles cnn
einschalten wo er doch als anchor vom
zdf eigentlich derjenige sein sondern
sollte der mit seinem sender live
entweder selber geht oder hinweist auf
dem korrespondenten vor ort der den mut
und die hitze hat sozusagen mit dem
schmalen equipment was zur verfügung
steht den zuschauern eine live
berichterstattung zu liefern und da gab
es intern in den öffentlich-rechtlichen
wirklich sozusagen krisenstäbe die sich
darüber wirklich ernsthafte gedanken
gemacht haben wie sie die aktualität bei
solchen spontanen einsätzen auf
vordermann bringen und diese information
ist was worauf der gebührenzahler meiner
meinung nach in recht hat denn er
bezahlt und wenn wir von unseren
intendanten immer wieder hören dass wir
ein modernes medienunternehmen sein was
er impliziert dass es eigentlich
privatwirtschaftlich ausgerichtet sein
soll dann muss man entweder auf gebühren
verzichten wenn das wirklich stimmt oder
andersherum wenn wir eine anstalt sind
mit gebührengeldern dann sollte doch der
einzelne der auch bezahlt ein
mitspracherecht haben als wäre ein
aktionär das ist doch ein schönes pwg
von ihnen bevor wenn eine ganz kurze
unterbrechungen und wir sind gleich
wieder zurück und dann sprechen wir über
karl lauterbach
also da kann ich ja ein lauter brauchen
und nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren nachtleben der schlagend sein
machen mein name ist wieder fit
so nicht
herr jörg berger ist aber niemand von
den politischen parteien traut sich zu
sagen ja das wollen wir einfach nur
freiheit diese grün-roten der damen
führen hochtrabende debatten über die
rettung des weltklimas und um die füße
ruhen die ratten das thema ist viel zu
wichtig um es nur der afg zugewandert
lasst den leuten doch mal den spaß wir
sehen ja etwas was eigentlich fatale ist
in der politik bei den journalisten
deren job ist es doch gerade hat eine
meinung zu führen und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig gut an seinem wagen
eines quasi zum manko vielleicht einmal
sein das auto im web haben wir ganz
nennen doch was ist übrig andrack träger
ausdrücken ich habe meinen beifall um
eine sache immer bekommen er kümmert
sich darum niemand ist bei federer
man muss da ganz klar auf dem
versprechen ganz einfach nicht der hat
mich richtig ist die karte mädchen nicht
begraben nur noch vier wochen
[Musik]
wir machen jetzt direkt weiter mit herr
gross und ich möchte nämlich sehen ob am
ende der sendung vielleicht paul
ronzheimer und groß ja doch noch freunde
werden also gilt es keine zeit zu
verlieren und wir legen los mein team
hat dass ich ihnen heute mitbringe
24 monate wurden wir von angst von panik
von hysterie von lok tanz von masken
pflicht von grünen bässen und
abstandsregeln gequält unsere grund und
freiheitsrechte wurden eingeschränkt
eine litanei von gerichtsverfahren und
urteilen auch in deutschland aber auch
vor dem verfassungsgerichtshof in
österreich zeigen dass die verfassung
gebrochen wurde unter der abstrakten
gefahr eines virus war es möglich
freiheitsrechte einzuschränken
wir haben kollektiven selbstmord
begangen aus angst vor dem corona tod 24
monate später ist ja wir müssen den satz
formulieren die pandemie ist zu ende
omega und zeigt uns dass die
gefährlichkeit des virus abgenommen hat
ein zehntel dem der grippe nunmehr ist
israel beerdigt seine maßnahmen den
grünen passt die niederlande dänemark
großbritannien die schweiz schweden nur
österreich und deutschland beharrt auf
diesem weg der angst und panik in
deutschland stellt deutschlands
gesundheitsminister lauterbach in
aussicht dass die pandemie in zehn
jahren noch nicht zu ende sein wird ich
prophezeie die pandemie ist zu ende
genauso wie die junge amtszeit des
deutschen gesundheitsministers karl
lauterbach
an der stelle stellt sich natürlich für
den otto normalverbraucher oder für mich
die frage was glauben sie denn warum
herr lauterbach mit dieser prognose der
nächsten zehn jahre überhaupt erst
das überhaupt suggeriert oder das
öffentlich macht glauben sie wirklich
dass er diese angst und panik hat was
der gesundheit in der wunde radgruppen
angeht oder glauben sie er dass es
politische hintergründe hat oder
vielleicht andere vorteile ich glaube es
ist ein gemisch aus geistiger
beschäftigungslosigkeit und dass einem
angst und panikstörungen die lauterbach
offenbar für sich inhaliert hat wie es
trösten ja auch nicht anders sieht ich
erinnere an kosten der 2006 mit
schweinegrippe den gleichen ziel oper
aufführen wollte wie es nun draußen dann
mit merkel und sparen geschafft hat und
lauterbach nun vollzieht es ist eine
mischung aus angst und panik es ist eine
mischung aus wichtigtuerei und das ist
eine mischung aus einem ungleichgewicht
wir geben den biologen und medizinern
die gesamte politische macht obwohl die
politik die an auf die aufgabe hätte zu
gewichten die psychische gesundheit der
menschen die physische gesundheit der
menschen die wirtschaftliche gesundheit
des stapels die soziale gesundheit
unseres gesamten gefüge wenn es nämlich
so einfach wäre dann räumen wir in
berlin die charité aus ersetzen sie auf
der regierungsbank die nächsten vier
jahre und schmeißen unsere politik auf
den misthaufen so einfach ist es eben
nicht denn der bundestag besteht aus
volksvertretern und daher appelliere ich
an die volksvertreter in österreich und
in deutschland vielleicht nach 24
monaten so etwas wie vernunft wieder
walten zu lassen frau sei aber wir
wurden in die cola maßnahme wurde auch
karl lauterbach innerhalb des öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunks wahrgenommen ich
habe ja gesagt ich muss ja bestehen ich
habe als bürgerin kritische kommentare
vermisst wobei das zdf noch besser war
als das muss ich wirklich sagen als zdf
war dann doch noch etwas mutiger finde
ich also ich kann wirklich nicht für das
gesamte zdf er sein programm sprechen
ich kann nur persönlich sagen dass wir
vor allem ein problem mit der
diskriminierung haben und dass dieser
grundsatz hat diskriminierungsfreiheit
ist im zdf staatsvertrag verankert
genauso wie er auch in der ard im
rundfunkstaatsvertrag verankert ist
dieses prinzip haben wir auf
verschiedensten arten und weisen in
programmen nicht mehr gegeben also
sprich wir hören eine indien kämen die
jetzt sehr beliebte moderatorin für die
wissenschaftssendungen auch gerade für
die jüngere zielgruppe die dann einen
ein video in social media eröffnet mit
dem satz also alle ungeimpften können es
gleich mal abschalten da ist für mich
der grundsatz der
diskriminierungsfreiheit nicht mehr
gewährleistet und das ist das was mich
bei herrn lauterbach besonders
beschäftigt dass er das von anfang an
bis jetzt durchgezogen hat und sich
dafür überhaupt nicht geniert und dass
das wirklich wie sie schon richtig
gesagt haben gegen unsere eigentlich
unser grundgesetz verstößt ich beziehe
mich natürlich ist da immer auf den
staatsvertrag weil mich das auch
interessiert wie sich das zdf da verhält
und das hätte er fährt aber da natürlich
auch ein problem weil zum beispiel jetzt
letzten juni amtlich wurde gerichtlich
eine frontal21 reporterin hat es quasi
gerichtlich bewiesen dass das zdf seine
frauen schlechter bezahlt als männer da
ist auch diskriminierung im spiel ganz
klar das ist also jetzt amtlich und
trotzdem ist es immer neues bewiesen
dass beim zdf die weiblichen reporter
schlechter bezahlt wenn hat sie männlich
nicht nur die reporter sondern überhaupt
die mitarbeiter also es gibt ja dieses
jahr 2017 dieses gesetz nachdem man sich
erkundigen ob die männlichen kollegen
mit vergleichbarer tätigkeit gleich viel
oder mehr verdienen als frau diese
reporterin war aber nur im dritten kreis
hat jetzt also hierarchien die
schlechtmöglichste
einstellungs stufe also eigentlich
scheinselbständigkeit da hat man dieses
recht nicht das muss man sich erst auch
erst mal reinziehen man das mit
lohnsteuerkarte beim zdf hat aber kein
informationsrecht dieses auskunft recht
hat sie sich erst mal erstritten um dann
zu erfahren wie gesagt das ging dann bis
zum bundesarbeitsgericht dass das also
system hat und sagt dass die frauen
schlechter verdient als die männer und
daran hat sich bis heute nichts geändert
würde jetzt gerne hier einfach das
exotisch natürlich nochmal paul fragen
aber leider ist paul einige hierarchie
stufen über wir uns solche deswegen auch
hoffentlich mehr verdienen aber deswegen
die frage an dich paul muss karl
lauterbach weg
nein karl lauterbach muss nicht weg ich
finde das spannend das gerät bohrt sich
in den kreis derjenigen ein bereit weil
bitte nach acht die erst gesagt haben
herr lauterbach würde auf gar keinen
fall gesundheitsminister dann in den
koalitionsverhandlungen noch mal gesagt
haben dann ein dass er schon
entschlossen herr lauterbach wird auf
gar keinen fall gesundheitsminister und
jetzt anfangen zu sagen hatte war es
seien ja die ist eigentlich schon fast
vorbei ich glaube da muss man
manifestieren dass die große mehrheit
der deutschen
seltsamerweise ist gar nicht so schlecht
findet wenn jemand immer noch warnt und
warnt und immer noch darauf hinweist wie
vielleicht doch gefährlich oder auch
nicht bewohner ist das lässt allerdings
nach von daher wird es spannend zu sehen
sein wie sich der lauterbacher
entwickelt ich muss sagen ich finde ihn
als politischer politikertyp irgendwie
sympathisch ich weiß da stehe ich
vielleicht relativ verhalten mit meiner
meinung bewirkt aber ich mag ihn wie er
auftritt er lässt sich anbrüllen
anschreit am nächsten tag wieder in die
sendung lena du hast du ja auch da
ich habe erlebt wie wolfgang kubicki ihn
damals
berichtet hat wieder in seiner kneipe
über ihn gesprochen wird und ihn als
dumpfbacken und spacken bezeichnet also
so hat die kneipe angeblich über ihn
gesprochen und die beiden haben sich
dann auch wieder vertragen also als
rheinische auch so ein bisschen
frohnatur wenn auch eher professor natur
mag ich ihn irgendwie unabhängig davon
muss er sich auch politisch beweisen
jetzt komm ich jetzt sozusagen zum ernst
zurück tatsächlich ist es so dass er das
corona thema irgendwann wegfällt und
dann geht es um die großen themen die
viele menschen in deutschland bewegen
zum beispiel die frage was in der pflege
passiert was ist mit unseren
gesundheitsbeiträge und bei all diesen
themen wie er sich beweisen müssen dass
ein ministerium möglich führen kann das
hat er finde ich bislang noch nicht
bewiesen und das wird er ab musste aber
man muss sich doch solange sorgen machen
so lang kann auch in dieser häufigkeit
überhaupt twitter-meldungen absetzt und
überhaupt öffentlich ist also so ist er
ja überhaupt minister geworden das finde
ich medial wiederum eine spannende frage
wie wird man heute eigentlich minister
es handelt sich ja nicht unbedingt um
eine kompetenzprüfung die man
durchlaufen muss sondern die häufigkeit
der thematisierung in den medien und vor
allem wenn es nur darum geht dass mein
tv shows auftrat wie gesagt man kann der
bundespräsident werden also ich hoffe
mit blick auf karl lauterbach dann noch
hoffnung aber an alzheimer falsch es ist
keine prognose dass er da kürzt die für
systemen gesundheitsminister wird es ist
ein heimlicher wunsch von mir der in
österreich und deutschland sind
mittlerweile das letzte übriggebliebene
versuchslabor der sogenannten corona
maßnahmen der autokratischen maßnahmen
wir sind übrig geblieben alle länder in
europa haben die pandemie für beendet
erklärt nur in österreich oder in
deutschland verspürt man uns so eine
sadomasochistische lust sich zu knechten
oder sich knechten zu lassen oder die
knechtschaft sich ausrichten zu lassen
als karl lauterbach der lustige typ ist
bei uns erklärt dass unsere freiheit die
nächsten 20 jahre zehn jahre wird flöten
geht dann ist man vielleicht in einem
gestrengen keller besser aufgehoben
würde ich habe mal sagen also ich gehöre
nicht zu denen ich bin ein sehr
freiheitsliebender in sehr liberaler
mensch und ich will meine alte
normalität und meine freiheit wieder
zurück nicht die freiheiten die kleinen
die sie uns gegeben sondern die freiheit
und um die geht wir bleiben beim thema
corona denn frau peetz hat uns auch
geht's immer mitgebracht und es geht ums
impfen also seien sie froh dass ich
heute nicht was ich spreche
ja also bei meinem thema geht es nicht
direkt um simple sondern eher um die
thematik wie es im internationalen sport
bereich und vermutlich auch in vielen
anderen bereichen des gesellschaftlichen
und sozialen lebens aussieht und da
natürlich als sportlerin habe ich
hautnah miterlebt wie es meinen
kolleginnen vor allem letztes jahr zum
teil sogar noch in diesem jahr geht da
zum beispiel russische kolleginnen oder
chinesische kolleginnen oder eben leute
aus kasachstan oder aus staaten der
ehemaligen sowjetunion gar keine chance
haben den richtigen impfstoff zu
bekommen um dann die erlaubnis zu
bekommen in deutschland oder in anderen
eu staaten australien oder usa überhaupt
am spielbetrieb teilzunehmen und das
wiederum führt dazu dass mittlerweile
jetzt international viele wettbewerber
dadurch nicht mehr in der stärke und was
die besten sportler des landes angeht
durchgeführt werden und meines erachtens
macht eben diese politik weil sie eben
zu einspurig in einigen ländern ist den
sportbetrieb und natürlich auch den
gedanken des sports die vereinigung von
vielen ländern
kulturen und religionen komplett kaputt
da geht es ja um teilnahme freiheit also
eigentlich auch ein wichtiger grundsatz
ich frag mich da und dann würde mich mal
interessieren wie sie das sehen ob wir
dann nicht weltweit jetzt vielleicht
auch mal eine art von neuer diskurs und
regelungen brauchen wie wir mit
hierarchien umgehen wie wir mit den
verschiedenen kategorien umgehen
überhaupt entscheidungen zu treffen denn
da müssen sich regierungen darüber
austauschen dann müssen sich
gesundheitsministerien austauschen das
braucht sie eine ganz andere art von
struktur und natürlich sollte ich das
ziel sein von bürokratie
runterzukommen und weniger struktur
einzuziehen als jetzt noch mehr
andererseits muss es natürlich
irgendwann die mechanismen geben den man
jetzt einführt damit man sich dann neu
verständigen kann und ihr beispiel ist
ja eigentlich das beste dass wir das
jetzt brauchen das liegt ja auf der hand
wie sehen sie das natürlich brauchen wir
das und na klar liegt es auf der hand
und es gibt ja solche strukturen das ist
dann die struktur innerhalb der eu und
in australien und amerika wo man halt
mit dem falschen impfstoff oder mit dem
falschen land wo man dann den richtigen
impfstoff erst bekommt halt nicht
teilnehmen kann und da müsste es eine
korrespondenz zwischen allen ländern
dieser welt geben und alleine schon
durch die politische lage in der wir
jetzt sind ist es ein ding der
unmöglichkeit das witzige für mich an
der stelle ist das zum beispiel jetzt in
meinem bereich die internationalen
wettkämpfe in der ehemaligen so wetten
dass in den staaten der ehemaligen
sowjetunion im osten für jeden sportler
möglich sind aha im vergleich dazu in
der eu als auch in australien und in
amerika es eben nicht möglich ist das
heißt diese drei gruppen von ländern
sind die einzigen täter wirklich
barrieren schaffen und das finde ich
eigentlich sehr sehr schade dafür dass
wir eben in einem land in einem landwirt
grundrecht mit freiheitsrechte und so
groß geworden sind was meinen sie was
sind die sozusagen die hemden schuhe
oder wo geht das eigentlich los ist es
das geld oder sind es die ideologische
hintergründe sind das sozusagen die
politischen strukturen was ist da
eigentlich entscheidend also ich
vermutet dass es politische sachen sind
weil für mich ist es unlogisch dass man
jetzt hier sagt zum beispiel in
deutschland naja sputnik oder sie nowak
schützt nicht so sehr deswegen ist es
klar dass die leute die neben mit diesen
impfstoff geimpft wurden mit gefahr
darstellen am spielbetrieb in
deutschland teilzunehmen wenn eben in
den ländern wie zum beispiel russland
oder china die länder dann davon
überzeugt sind dass sputnik als auch so
nowack gute impfstoffe sind die gegen
korona schützen dann haben wir ja
verschiedene sichtweisen und dann ist es
für mich schwer zu verstehen warum diese
eine sichtweise dann alle anderen
ausgrenzt
kannst du das nachvollziehen warum es
nicht dann erlaubt ist oder nicht
angesehen ist beispielsweise mit sputnik
geimpft zu sein
ja das ist eine interessante frage weil
natürlich in der ukraine nicht bin der
impfstoff wie sputnik noch einmal eine
ganz andere emotionale aufladung hat
nämlich weil dieser in russland
produziert worden ist und das ganze hier
natürlich zwischen den beiden ländern
hoch emotional diese debatte geführt
wird aber ich möchte das noch mal aus
der anderen perspektive betrachten denn
ich habe gerade darüber nachgedacht als
ihr über corona geredet hat wie wenig
ich eigentlich in den letzten wochen
über coconut nachgedacht habe weil ich
in einem land das größere probleme hat
nämlich vor allem krieg steht oder in
einem krieg steht und inwieweit chor
oder plötzlich keine rolle mehr spielt
aber ist dann auch gar kein thema mehr
ist und ist irgendwie auch nicht so
richtig so aussieht als würde diese
gesellschaft in der ukraine zumindest
momentan von corona wahnsinnig
heimgesucht ich habe das getan oder
statistiken zu weil er auch weniger
getestet weniger geimpft und so weiter
wird aber das ist mir schon in vielen
krisen ländern so gegangen in die ich
bereist bin während der korona hat unter
anderem auch in afghanistan das
plötzlich wenn etwas wichtiger wird als
büro oder das thema plötzlich wie
weggeflogen ist und ich kann euch sagen
es gut alles gut auch wenn es hier ein
drängenderes und schwieriges thema gibt
gross wie schaffen wir es dass es auch
in deutschland wächst da sind sie jetzt
eigentlich wieder einer meinung das ist
weg fliegen muss es muss weg fliegen und
wir leben
paul ronzheimer hat es gesagt dass sehr
viele menschen verständnis hätten für
maßnahmen das wäre in umfragen
ausgedrückt wir erleben dass nach 24
monaten
sehr viele menschen sich an die
unfreiheit gewöhnt haben und wir leben
vor allem dass ältere generation sagen
bitte behalten die maßnahmen bei weil
sie sich vor dem virus zu fürchten ich
sage die gesellschaft ist von heraus
dass ich heute sehr ruhig bei wir sind
ja am ende angekommen haben wir gemerkt
sie ist wenn sie einen smart wieder dein
maries besser schöner und bis morgen
[Musik]